[Music]
all right democrats
have reached i think the obvious
conclusion that their only path sure
path to victory
is the burn it all down approach of the
neo-bolsheviks on the streets
joe biden's team has formed common cause
with those who
not only seek the destruction of the
nuclear family if you don't believe me
check out blm's website
they've actually decided that promoting
racial hatred
is the only way they can win they know
that trump's policies
it's obvious have delivered results for
working people of all races
while theirs have largely failed now the
left hopes that by inflaming racial
division
and hiding their candidate they can
avoid a real debate on the issues
so over the weekend the president
responded with two
powerful speeches to celebrate our
independence and identify the domestic
forces now threatening it his remarks at
mount rushmore reaffirmed america's
identity
and inspired millions of americans
who've
basically been living in despair because
of the one-two punch of the virus
and the continuing riots these radicals
would tear down the very heritage
for which men gave their lives to win
the civil war
they would tear down the principles that
propelled
the abolition of slavery
and ultimately around the world ending
an evil institution that had plagued
humanity for
thousands and thousands of years
our opponents would tear apart the very
documents
that martin luther king used to express
his dream
they would tear down the beliefs culture
and identity
that have made america the most vibrant
and tolerant society
in the history of the earth we will
proclaim the ideals
of the declaration of independence and
we will never surrender the spirit and
the courage
and the cause of july 4th
1776. upon this ground we will stand
firm and unwavering in the face of lies
meant to divide us demoralize
us and diminish us now you can
always tell how effective one of the
president's speeches is
by how friendly frenzied the reaction
from liberals
i actually thought it was some fantasy
he's just desperate there was
a lot about history about god and our
great country
much of it very ominous there was no
attempt here
to unify the country it was a divisive
message the president threw down the
cultural war gauntlet in defense
of dead white men inflammatory hateful
watching it you realize how disturbed
and how disturbing this president really
is
you notice i described liberals and
kasich and jennifer rubin are among them
you bet now if lying was an olympic
sport
these folks would be draped in gold
medals
in moments of rare candor they know that
trump beats biden hands down on jobs and
wages for african americans
trump beats biden on education he favors
liberation for parents and students
who are stuck in bad schools trump beat
biden on prison reform
obama and biden both talked a good game
they didn't get it done
and of course trump has done something
that by never did
he has actually hired and promoted
african americans and other minorities
across as many businesses
now where biden and democrats are
content to patronize african americans
with
these meaningless symbolic gestures
conservatives actually believe that
minorities want what all people want a
fair chance at prosperity
and to pursue their happiness in freedom
and safety
trump knows this is only possible with a
vibrant growing economy
where all criminals are prosecuted
meanwhile biden thinks he can surf to
victory on racial anger
stoked by mobs many of whom are white
who would rather see
every city in america burn than a second
trump term
now this requires a massive effort to
lie and defame
one that an honest press would have
exposed long ago
now as i've said before instead of
covering the democrats
the media cover for them
their tactics and their toxic
associations i'm talking about
so long as the endgame of any activist
or politician is to rid america of trump
oh the press will excuse all manner of
falsehoods hypocrisy
and even criminality so to stoke racial
tension the biden campaign requires
a massive effort to lie and defame
one that of course would have already
been exposed
long ago now when you think back when
you think about how this whole thing
went down
how did it go down it went down after
this
long shutdown people had a lot of time
on their hands
again if we continue to allow
these lies and this ongoing slander and
defamation to continue
well what happens people will continue
to lose
faith in the system of laws
and even in equal protection
you know people looters got a bad name
during the you know george floyd
protests
but thank goodness for the looters man
um you have a place called target you
have a store called target you're gonna
be a target
you know these places have absolutely
contributed to
the oppression now
the left is even trying to get the
broadway sensation
hamilton cancelled if you think that's
wacky
it is that's right there is a cancel
hamilton hashtag out there
now never mind that all the key roles
including those of alexander hamilton
and george washington are played by
people of color in the musical
critics say it glosses over key facts
they claim hamilton was not an
abolitionist and traded slaves for his
in-laws the mere fact that it celebrates
the founding
era in any positive way to good music
is ample reason for the left to call for
its cancellation
now the only thing at this point that's
sacred
to them is the notion that if you're a
leftist
you cannot be questioned or prosecuted
for crimes
yeah ends justify the means you bet they
do
past grievances mean never having to say
you're sorry
the media will give you a pass for
anything at the same time
they spy racism around every corner
says he was assaulted by two masked men
who yelled out
racial and homophobic slurs police are
investigating the incident as a possible
hate crime
a horrifying racist incident heinous
heinous ugly
crude and cowardly way hate crime
nascar is investigating a horrible
incident
a noose was found in the garage stall
of bubba wallace much as nascar may try
to distance itself from that
it's a living breathing part of their
sport well and then when trump calls him
on it albeit via an
in our fully worded tweet he becomes the
target
do you believe the president sees racism
as a potential path to reelection
look there's no doubt that uh and i've
said this before this president his
political calculus is all about
division not addition and why does the
left do all this
well simple to deflect from the
democrats own horrific record
on race the economy and crime
this is now a third week in a row where
we have seen children
shot and killed here which was part of a
weekend where we saw more than 60 people
shot and over a dozen people killed so
just point blank
what is happening right now the
ecosystem of public safety
that isn't just law enforcement but as
local community based
and they too have really been hit hard
by covid
and are now just kind of coming back
online
and getting their footing what
can you just hear that chicago's seen a
tragic level of violence since the black
lives matter
marches started and it's claiming
african-american lives and costing the
black community
dearly the bad guys here aren't the
folks going to mount rushmore
they're criminals murdering children on
the streets of our nation's third
largest city
80 people were shot and 17 killed in
chicago last week
week weekend alone and at least 13 of
those
were african-american and it gets even
more tragic
including among the dead as a
seven-year-old natalia wallace
she was shot in the head she was
visiting her grandmother for the fourth
of july
and sadly she wasn't the only child
killed in southeast dc 11-year-old devon
mcneil
shot and killed at a fourth of july
cookout with his family
arm thugs in atlanta murdered
eight-year-old sequoia turner
near the wendy's where rayshard brooks
died at the hands of police
now this is senseless and awful killing
and it's
obviously left her parents heartbroken
shattered and asking why
they say black lives matter you killed
your home
get your own inside there because of
barrier
they killed my baby because she crossed
the barrier and made a u-turn you killed
a child
she didn't do nothing to nobody now
every single one of these cities
is run by democrats and rather than
addressing
violent crime drugs and fatherlessness
plaguing so many communities
they just make excuses they throw out
phrases like systemic racism
unconscious bias or white privilege and
minimizing the importance of personal
responsibility
love of one's neighbor and the value of
every human life
so rather than insisting on law and
order safety in every community
including
african-american communities this is the
best they can offer
we talk about systemic racism
and the trauma and the anxiety and you
think about the leadership or the lack
thereof
that we have coming from the highest
office in the land
um i i think that you are seeing so many
emotions
play out and and so too
often it's playing out in violence in
our streets
emotions are playing out
i think some folks are still trying to
pretend that
all of this mayhem will stop if we just
let the democrats have the white house
well we have the democrats
in power in atlanta and chicago in new
york in baltimore and beyond and beyond
what's happened so this thinking is
foolish and naive
the democrats have shown they're utterly
unwilling to restrain the hard left from
seizing property and committing violence
and as for the culture wars
why would the radicals stop when they
think they're winning
so ignore the folks who say that it just
gets better when we let the democrats
have more power
the only way this situation gets better
is for democrats to lose and lose so
often that they're forced to apologize
for their relentless slandering of our
nation's history
and by extension the majority of our
citizens who still
unapologetically love this country and
still believe
that it's worth celebrating and that's
the angle
now if a tree falls in a forest
and no one's around to hear it does it
make a sound
well that's the age-old philosophical
thought experiment about perception
and observation but after this weekend
we can modify it this way
if a trump march draws tens of thousands
maybe hundreds of thousands of peaceful
patriotic people to washington and no
one's around to report it
did it really occur well it was billed
as the million maga march that's more
than tens of thousands
uh and you look at it by the overhead
shots it could be one of the biggest
grassroots protests
the capital has ever seen attendees were
families
young old black white hispanic they came
from near and far
all to support the america first agenda
and to stand with the man who has
endured so much
in order to lead the movement
[Music]
trump
one thing after another you know and uh
the american people know it
you know and you can see by the support
you got to make sure our president get
back in that office
now it's a fair guess that most in that
gigantic crowd are convinced that trump
won the election
and it's likewise reasonable for them to
conclude that
they don't have much trust in the u.s
media
now pockets by the way were even
chanting against this news channel for
what they perceive
as election night bias against the
president others
were rightfully outraged that few
networks were even carrying the rally at
all
and the ones who did were only
interested in insulting the attendees
the president's supporters they poured
into the streets of washington this
weekend
to try to give life to these unfounded
and baseless claims of a rigged election
how did this become normal i think with
some of these demonstrators good luck
getting a clear or fact-based logical
answer to some of the questions
you're opposing these people are
fundamentally a joke
these aren't serious people these are
members of a cult i hope they get
frostbite i hope they get frostbite
that's what he said
now remember these talking heads are
some of the kind
tolerant unifying and loving people
that biden and harris claim make up
their movement
well 73 million people voted for
president trump and it's
it's not too much for them to expect is
it that the media treat them fairly
and respectfully likewise it's not too
much for them to expect that only
legal votes will be counted and that
their votes
must not be nullified due to fraud
now for years now i've been speaking uh
about this type of honest hard-working
americans who came to washington over
the weekend
and throughout this time the so-called
elites in our nation's capital
have responded to the legitimate
concerns of american citizens with
mockery and contempt it's dumbfounding
to me
that the media and democrats still don't
understand what a stupid strategy
strategy it is to alienate and dismiss
all of these americans i think they're
they're making the same mistake they
made back in 2009 and 2010
when the much smaller tea party movement
started
did you see the tea party movement as a
real political force this year
look i i uh
it seems to be a very successful private
enterprise
nobody actually knows what they're for
we just know what they are against it's
not about
taxes this is about hating a black man
in the white house we call it astro turf
it's not really a grassroots movement
those of you who are watching certain
news channels that
in which i'm not very popular
and you see folks waving tea bags around
they thought that all that condescension
would make the movement go away
but it only made the tea party stronger
less than two years after those insults
republicans took control
of the house in 2010. now some of the
tea party candidates included those
little-known people
christie gnome marco rubio ted cruz
rand paul tim scott and mike lee
and four years later the gop took
control of the senate
two years after that donald trump was
elected president
now the difference between the tea party
then and president trump's movement now
is that this movement now has a lot more
clarity about what it wants
the same trump economic and foreign
policy agenda that led to higher wages
fewer wars and whatever the final
electoral college tally is in this
election
this movement has a proven track record
of success on everything from achieving
our energy independence
to challenging china to fast-tracking a
coveted vaccine to raising family
incomes
the results were so impressive that not
only did president trump broaden his
coalition among working-class americans
but he helped grow the party's numbers
in the house
when all those wanted media experts with
all their credentials
were predicting the opposite they
claimed trump was going to shrink the
party remember that especially among
minorities
wrong again blacks and latinos are doing
much better on the trump
versus obama yeah yeah absolutely
[Music]
you've done a lot of things and i've
been seeing a lot of business come to my
neighborhood
i missed a lot of black home uh black
people on homes
why couldn't the networks find these
people to interview they were there
we found them in a biden administration
that that you just saw all those gains
gonna be flushed down the toilet his
handlers who are basically all the old
obama staffers believe in something
called the great reset of capitalism i
told you about this last week
it's a plan to force a more equitable
distribution of global resources
translation most americans will have
less freedom
and less money except for the same
elites who always find a way around the
rules
like during the lockdowns when the
families of these mini tyrants
skirted the restrictions just like last
week
california governor gavin newsom was
dining with a prohibited number
of pals at that exclusive restaurant the
french laundry
chicago mayor lori lightfoot was caught
partying maskless
in a massive crowd celebrating biden's
unofficial election win no problem at
all and pelosi
well she was going to have a big
congressional soiree until she was
shamed into cancelling it
the american people are on to these
frauds
the magamarcher certainly couldn't have
been clearer about what love coveted
lockdowns and restrictions
have done to america it's like you know
what trump said in the beginning
the cure can't be worse than the disease
itself
you know people we still need to go on
trying to finish off any
business that was able to hang on by the
skin of their teeth and the last
closures they'll finish them off people
are hurting you know nancy pelosi joe
biden they don't talk about caring about
the american people but you shut this
country down for four to six weeks
and you're going to absolutely it'll be
the final nail in the coffee for a lot
of small businesses
100 true but so far joe biden and his
handlers aren't listening
biden loves to talk about dignity and
unity and respect
but the time for talk is over and the
time for action is here
because if biden really wanted to unite
the country he wouldn't even be
entertaining the idea of destroying our
current economic recovery
with another devastating lockdown or
series of lockdowns
if biden really wanted to unite the
country he would not dismiss the
concerns
of tens of millions of americans about
mail-in voting
instead he'd do something like i don't
know appoint a bipartisan commission to
answer
every question about how this election
was conducted
and to make certain that we will never
have to wait so long for an accurate
count
and if joe biden really wanted to unite
the country he would have
personally and on camera condemn the blm
and antifa thugs who beat kicked
and harassed trump's supporters on
saturday
he has done none of these things he
still hopes this movement's just going
to go away
but that's not going to happen here are
a few hard truths for joe biden
his handlers and his enablers in the
press corps you know who you are
the pro-trump throngs didn't show up in
dc on saturday because of conservative
media
because we told them to they showed up
knowing they could be physically
attacked for doing so
because they love america
and lying about them insulting them
ignoring them
will only incite more violence and more
resentment
and opposition all americans deserve to
be heard
to be seen and to be safe it's the least
a government can do for its citizens
and that's the angle
but if the press were actually doing its
job
you'd be hearing a lot about the
bloomberg new economy forum which has
been going on
all week attended by modern day global
leaders and wealthy elites who supported
joe biden
and they're so confident in their agenda
so buoyed by
what they see as the defeat of the
america first movement
that they aren't even trying to hide
their disdain any longer
for american sovereignty were you
surprised by how
how badly america is done on that very
quickly
it's mind-blowing when the paris
agreement came into force the united
states withdrew
from it and left us and all the other
countries
around the world is disappointed the
marketplace is encouraged by
having a leader now that is more
inclusive
inclusive of course if they have their
way
you're going to have no say in the
future of the global economy no way to
affect it no ability to change it
it's up to american patriots to oppose
what they're trying to do
at almost every turn and that means
supporting senators kelly loffler
and david perdue in georgia that runoff
on january 5th
and it means keeping pressure on
republican elected officials across the
board
let's face it before trump a lot of them
were wrong
on both trade and immigration got to
keep an eye on them
and over the next four years these
republicans are going to come
under enormous media and financial
pressure
to appease the global elites and make no
mistake about it the globalists are
determined to ram
through their agenda and given biden's
age and mental acuity or lack thereof
they probably feel like
they have a very narrow window very
short window to achieve their grand
designs
if biden gets into office get ready for
the fight of your life
over the next years at every turn they
will try to subvert your rights
and take your prosperity to start
they're going to crater your personal
finances
with insane climate policies we need a
whole economy transition backing those
who are part of the solution and taking
capital away from those who are part of
the problem
a cap and trade mechanism or some kind
of carbon tax
an active carbon market with a carbon
price
that would continue to step up
in level every year guaranteed tax
increases on energy
would devastate the middle class but
they know that the elites know that
that's their entire point
remember now we made an appeal to aoc
to work with us to stop some of these
types of
crushing globalist deals but bloomberg
and his pals are really smart
they know exactly the kind of rhetoric
that's needed to win people like
alexandria ocasio-cortez over
climate change is going to kill us all
if we're waiting for things to be
delivered in 2050
we're not going to be around to see them
well we don't have a lot of time
somewhere between 10 and 20 years we
need to invest now
we don't have 10 or 12 years to build
new power stations we need them
in 18 months on trade which we
highlighted earlier this week bloomberg
and his globalist cronies made clear in
a special report
what their overriding goal is sticking
together by guarding
against the risk of the u.s and china
decoupling oh they don't want that
bloomberg and lots of other american
plutocrats have billions tied up in
china
so decoupling from the communist regime
would be a disaster for them personally
even though it would be a huge boon to
american industries
and american workers now on covid
billionaires like bill gates could
barely hide their excitement for what a
biden presidency might bring
people come into the country do they
have a digital certificate that says
whether they've been vaccinated or not
as the u.s rejoins the who this idea of
what is the vaccine certificate look
like hopefully that dialogue
uh will will begin show me your papers
now don't for a second think that you're
going to have a seat at that table
for this dialogue you're just supposed
to sit down
and do what you're told remember well
that's what dr fauci told us anyway
coincidentally the chinese cdc's chief
epidemiologist had basically the same
message yesterday
in the eastern culture we have
a community venue is higher than the
individual
venue in the united states and european
countries
the personal right it's the top
priority the most important is everybody
takes the order and follow the
instruction
everyone take the order and follow the
instruction or else do what you're told
mask up open your wallet distance
get the vaccine certificate give up your
freedom your autonomy
and do not under any circumstances ask
any real questions
does that sound like a fun world to live
in well this is the type of mentality
that will guide the biden
administration's coveted response
and of course good old joel will bend
over backwards to appease the world
health organization
a prospect that has emboldened world
health organization head dr
tedros the fastest way out of this
pandemic
is for us to work together in solidarity
across sectors and across
borders vaccine nationalism will prolong
the pandemic the pandemic has taken so
much from us
but it has also given us something
the opportunity to think afresh
about the world we want we can build
the healthier safer and
fairer world we all
want and build back better
there it is you think it's any
coincidence that tedros is borrowing
biden's campaign slogan or who's
borrowing from whom
these days it's a signal that they're
all on the same team
they all have the same end goals
individualism
and individual rights will be subverted
sublimated
to the global rights the communal rights
and it's a sign that joe biden
won't put america first he's not out to
make america better
and he won't make that his first
priority
he's got to do the bidding of bloomberg
wall street big business
and the rest of the special interest
that bank rolled his campaign
and of course that means kowtowing to
the elites who don't give a damn about
jobs and wages for americans
they never did that's why it's
imperative that we
hold the senate next year because with
the majority in that chamber
plus our gains in the house we actually
have a chance
at thwarting this kind of takeover of
the levers of power
from our government to a government far
far away
and we can make sure that the america
first movement continues to deliver
results
that our citizens and and we can use to
build a future where our children can
actually thrive
under the system of government and and
with our inalienable rights that we all
love and cherish and that's the angle